People still rock the bond though,
kind of respect that,
you know,
it's like driving a manual car.
I never was a bonger.
It's too heavy,
man.
I got shit to do,
I can't.
Oh,
that just fueled down.
I remember the Dab thing,
the,
I got friends in Colorado,
California now,
the first time I ever did with shit.
Uh,
this is pretty embarrassing story,
but my,
I didn't know what it was.
You know,
I just pulled it like it was a big old bomb rip and they're like,
everybody's face.
She was like,
Oh,
you know,
it was like,
I need,
you instantly know you just did something you shouldn't have.
Oh No.
And uh,
I was like,
ah,
fuck man.
So I sat down and looked at a couple of minutes.
I just started getting really cold and clammy.
I was like,
Yup,
I'm going to Puke.
So I went over,
I was like,
I'm fucked this guy.
So a puke rightness sink.
I was like,
dude,
I got to go home.
I feel like dog shit now.
And I'm pretty sure I'm dying.
So I had he,
we lived in this apartment and I was like,
we're out the door and turned the corner to go down the hallway to my,
and it was full on vertigo,
like the hall.
Every time I took a step,
the hall we got twice as long.
That was like,
this is fucked up.
My wife was out of the country and work at the time and I was like,
I remember was sitting down in the hallway just like trying to get my shit
together,
man.
Cause I was so,
I thought I was having a fucking heart attack.
It was just like pat,
like sweating.
And I remember this voice saying,
get up you stupid junkie.
Fuck before somebody comes out here and sees you,
you know,
sitting in the hallway like a dumb ass.
And I managed to like pop out of it and as soon as I get back to my place and
sit down on the couch,
everything was fine.
I don't,
nobody needs to be that stone
that fast.
I'm sorry.